scientists have to go into the world
they have to be sensitive to patterns
that need an explanation most patterns
don't need science because why they
happen is totally obvious so you have to
be able to spot things for which the
explanation is not obvious and you have
to be able to fill in the gap of what is
not clear with something that could in
principle be correct whether it is
correct or it's not it could answer the
question and that process of how you
generate hypotheses is actually one of
the hardest things to teach students
because it is a fundamentally creative
process it's not a science it's an art
and it's it's an art that a if each of
us who does it described our method it
doesn't sound very scientific all right
you know how do you bring yourself to
imagine a possible explanation for a
phenomenon that nobody knows the
explanation to you know ideas a kind of
a fantasy realm and it doesn't sound
rigorous and you know it isn't rigorous
it's guesswork and intuition and all
sorts of things that scientists pretend
are not an important part of the process
but nonetheless if you're going to be
good at science you have to be good at
this process and you have to give
yourself license for that creative
endeavor and so Heather and I both
discovered time and time again that it
was very straightforward to teach
students most of the process involved in
science but getting students to phrase a
question you know to see something to
phrase a question about it and then to
propose a hypothesis that could in
principle account for what it is that
they've observed it's a very difficult
method to teach and really you can't
really teach it what you have to do is
alert students to the fact that they
need to find their own process for it
and that they have license to I mean how
many wrong hypotheses do you imagine
that before you hit on one that actually
has the potential to be right tends to
be quite a number and so you you need to
give students license to think a bunch
of wrong things and to feel good about
it in order for them to get to something
that might be right but we're not easily
taught and frankly I don't even remember
it being described anywhere in my
education how you come up with a
hypothesis I don't remember anybody ever
explaining that to me at all huh yeah
it's it's one of those black box well
it's black boxes
yeah it is I guess that's that's the
catch-all but maybe that's why I use the
word part because that's just the
catch-all term for anything that you
like well it's another science because I
can't describe it but I know it when I
see it well yeah I guess you know what
does it mean for it to be an art is an
interesting question I think there are
lots of skills I think here's the
problem that was saying that it's an art
and it shouldn't be a problem that it is
that there is a corner of art at which
we've come to a level of abstraction
that whether something is good art or
bad art is completely an aesthetic
question it's entirely subjective that's
not true
if we're talking about a painter who is
depicting something in front of them
right
how well does the painter depicted is
actually a question it's not totally
objective but they could depict it so
poorly that nobody can tell what's in
the picture or they could depict it so
well that you couldn't possibly mistake
what's in the picture or they could do
something really amazing like a sure who
depict something that can't be and that
your brain is hung up trying to figure
out where the picture is inconsistent
but in some sense when we say something
is an art we are not talking about a
realm in which everything is subjective
what an art is is something in which the
method is not fully explicit and so
there's lots of parts of science in
which we can say what the method is the
part of science in which we can't say
what the method is is a little bit like
throwing a frisbee if I say throwing a
frisbee is an art there's physics to
making a frisbee do what you want it to
do most of us who throw a frisbee well
couldn't describe the physics and in
fact it's a little bit surprising when
you try because it's inconsistent you
know the physics of throwing a ball it's
much easier to understand in the physics
of the way a frisbee arcs you know
through its trajectory even but if he
tried to describe throwing a frisbee
while you're throwing a frisbee you're
gonna [ __ ] up that frisbee throw yeah
yeah you will because the part of your
mind that throws the frisbee isn't the
part of your mind that explicitly knows
physics it's some other part of your
mind that knows something that it would
be fair to call an art you know if you
watch people play Ultimate Frisbee you
know a really good player who knows how
to art the disc you know maybe even out
of bounds so that it comes back in right
at the place for the player that they
see running is going to end up it is
artistic right which is not to say the
haphazard or subjective or you know it's
finding a solution that has a air of
unexpectedness of it it's a skill that
isn't explicit yeah an art is a skill
that isn't explicit and so the
uncomfortable thing for us analytical
types I think is acknowledging how much
of things that we claim are explicit
really aren't you know your surgeon can
say an awful lot about what they do but
your surgeon also has a feel for stuff
that they don't even know how to they
don't explain it to themselves they they
Intuit it when they get there and you
know searching with a good intuition
versus well it's not so hot
intuition you want the one with the good
intuition even if what they know
explicitly explicitly is exactly the
same so I think those things that exist
in a realm where things are explicit
that fraction of an explicit realm that
is in fact not explicit and therefore an
art is very important and
hypothesis generation is very much of
this sort it is something it is
absolutely a skill and people differ
tremendously in their capacity to do it
well but even those of us who do it well
can't explain how we do it right we can
give you a little insight but mostly
it's some you know how do you muse right
yeah happen to you muse about a question
about nature it's it's very personal and
highly these idiots and cranek
you